[Music]
straight ahead all
on crime daily the widow of kobe bryant
vanessa
naming the deputies accused of sharing
photos of the deadly helicopter crash
the pending lawsuit and legal action and
free britney protesters are back in the
streets as the pop icon wants another
conservator appointed
to serve alongside her father britney
spears
deserves to be free after 13 years plus
more jurors are seated on the derek
shoven trial as we await a judge's
ruling on major decisions
the city of minneapolis defending his 27
million dollar settlement with the
family of george floyd
i'll note that it was a unanimous
decision law and crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
welcome everyone to long crime daily i'm
brian buckmeyer along with terry austin
two more jurors have been selected to
serve on the derek shove and murder
trial
law and crimes kim johnson is at the
hennepin county courthouse
and is here to break down day nine hi
brian
jury selection does continue here in
downtown minneapolis attorneys are
trying to agree on
14 impartial jurors that's 12 jurors
plus two alternates in derrick shovin's
murder trial as you said two additional
jurors
have been seated one is a white woman in
her 50s who works as a cardiac care
nurse
she was grilled about whether she can
avoid being an expert witness in
deliberations
and put aside previous professional
knowledge about resuscitation and
police's
split second decisions we have a clip of
that line of questioning take a listen
i recognize the amount of time that a
person can be
without air before they're unconscious
so how do you set aside your personal
training your personal knowledge
and judge the case on the facts as
presented in court
in that instance i'd have to weigh what
the expert
would say and then how the judge directs
to follow
the law now prosecutors wanted to know
if she sees patients with opioid
addiction
she said it is a growing problem and
acknowledge that addiction can affect
anyone another jurisdicted is a black
grandmother who volunteers at a youth
organization
she supports black lives matter has a
relative who works for the minneapolis
police department and supports them
as well with the addition of two jurors
wednesday the jury of
11 so far is nearly half men half women
half identify as white and half as
people
of color now friday is expected to be a
big day
in court judge peter cahill said that he
plans to
rule on emotions of whether to delay or
move this trial due to the high
publicity of a settlement
between the city and george floyd's
family
brian thanks kim outside of the
courthouse the minneapolis mayor
answered questions from reporters about
why the city announced the 27 million
dollar settlement
before the criminal case concluded we
got
you know very clear recommendations from
our attorneys given their legal
expertise
uh and you know i'll note that it was a
unanimous decision
uh coming from a very uh council with
many diverse
uh uh standpoints and backgrounds
there's no guarantee for instance that
that deal
would be available two four six
eight weeks from now or six months from
now
and we decided to move forward with the
floyd family
we are following the judge's
instructions and certainly
are not willing to speak about events
happening in that criminal trial in that
courtroom
it would be inappropriate i don't think
the judge would like us to say one
way or the other about the issues you
raised that are happening in the trial
right now
and that lawsuit was organized on behalf
of the george floyd family with the
assistance of attorney
benjamin crump joining us now is
criminal defense attorney suanne
robinson
an attorney for the ben crump law firm
suanne benjamin crump said this was a
historic settlement
what does it mean to have the city
settle at this amount
and in the middle of jury selection for
shroven's trial
i think it tells the public that when a
black person dies at the hands of
police brutality that it's worthy of
consequences and that their life is not
trivial and it in fact matters
and it happening right during the jury
selection gives the jury pool
that exact story the narrative that his
life mattered that it's not trivial and
that it's worthy of consequences
all right i think that's a lot of people
are seeing here both and the dollar
amounts i think benjamin crump said is
the highest amount
uh in terms of a wrongful death
pre-trial and then of course
the questions that follow uh let's bring
in co-host terry austin
terry since the settlement potential
jurors were questioned
if this settlement changed their opinion
but do you think it even should
well brian it should not influence their
opinion but
it could influence their opinion and
we've seen that it
has judge cahill made sure he questioned
those jurors
who were on the jury at that point in
time and he
ended up actually asking two of them
to leave because they basically said
that they had made certain assumptions
so
i don't think that it should influence
but clearly it
has technically the two suits have
nothing to do with the other
one is civil one is criminal one has
additional parties
the criminal suit does not and we know
that they're different standards
obviously in the criminal case it's
beyond a reasonable doubt
it's a preponderance of the evidence in
a civil case so they have
nothing to do with each other but
clearly jurors
are influenced when they hear about the
civil suit yeah we saw
two potential jurors excused because of
that suanne it looks like there will be
three experts in the case the defenses
the prosecution and the 10th juror are
cardiac carriers
is that risky or wise on the part of the
lawyers to have her on the jury
i think that it's risky in the sense
that i
under my understanding is that the
defense plan on giving a lot of medical
testimony so it could be risky if she's
in there and she in the jury room and
she's
asked questions and she has the
experience but every juror brings their
experience to the table it's whether or
not they can be
fair and impartial and look at the facts
and be fair and impartial
so i don't i think it could harm the
defense if they present
medical information that's different
from her understanding and her training
and she gives that information to her
fellow jurors but i also think that just
because of her life experience and her
work doesn't make
say that she can't be fair and impartial
it's gonna be interesting to see how
this all plays out thank you both
be sure to tune in to the law and crime
network for gavel to gavel coverage of
the derek chopin trial in the murder of
george floyd
still ahead on law and crime daily a
judge denies a motion to seal the names
of deputies who shared kobe bryant's
helicopter crash site photos
and vanessa bryants is naming names but
first the conservatorship battle
in the middle of the hashtag free
brittany movement continues see who was
arguing there should be another
[Music]
co-conservatory
[Music]
welcome back there's a new wrinkle in
the britney spears conservatorship
battle
as she tries to bring someone else on
board law and crimes anjanet levy is
here with the new details
brian someone britney spears had already
won one court battle with this
when she got the court to appoint
bessemer trust as a co-conservator to
help oversee her finances
now she is asking that someone else be
brought in as a co-conservator
to help her with her personal affairs
[Music]
supporters of britney spears bid to end
her conservatorship
flocked again to the courthouse as
spears asked that jody montgomery be
appointed as conservator of her personal
affairs
britney spears being free does not just
mean her dad being removed as
conservator
britney spears being free means her
being out of the conservatorship
entirely montgomery acted as spears
conservator when spears's father
jamie dealt with some health problems in
2019.
brittany's attorney has said she fears
her father and wants him removed
jamie spears has been conservator of
brittany's estate since 2008
his attorney told good morning america
that jamie loves his daughter
and has protected her from people
looking to take advantage of her
he has collaborated with her he when she
is up for performing she has performed
when she wants to record an album
she can record an album and when she
wants to live her life the way she wants
like a normal person
he has collaborated with her to do that
as well attorney vivian thorin disputes
britney has ever mentioned
fearing her dad anytime there's that
amount of money to be made
you have to question the motives of
everyone close
to that person britney spears
conservatorship
has received a lot of attention after a
new york times documentary
framing britney spears was released it
suggested britney's father was
controlling her
because of the massive amount of money
to be made off of her image
fans of britney spears are fueling the
free brittany movement
a movement that appears to be gaining
steam a lot more people
have been becoming aware because of
things in the media and this movement
and brittany means a lot to me
now it appears that britney spears wants
jody montgomery to share these duties
with her father
over her personal affairs which would
further limit jamie spears's say
in her life the judge will rule on this
latest request
next month brian thanks back to discuss
the latest in the conservatorship of
britney spears is criminal defense
attorney suanne robinson
and terry austin so when britney spears
won the financial battle it seems
is this now a push to get more autonomy
in her personal life
definitely brittany is suffering from
a conservative ship that was first
placed upon her 12 years ago
is it right that's something that a
breakdown that happened 12 years ago
today they're still questioning her
ability to take care of herself to make
her own personal decisions to have
that autonomy i don't think it's fair i
think she should have her autonomy and
her personal affairs
she's 38 years old and she's clearly
been able to maintain her career
throughout this entire
thing so she should be giving back her
personal affairs at minimum
now terry could this be a power play to
slowly push jamie spears out
of controlling britney spears life
absolutely brian i think we are all an
adamant agreement and certainly
britney's fans are an adamant agreement
that her father is slowly being moved
out but he should just be moved out
remember when she asked the court to
move him
out of the conservatorship what they did
is like antoinette said
they put bessemer trust as the
co-conservator so bessemer trust handled
the financial affairs
but the father was still handling the
personal affairs
now what she's doing is saying look this
montgomery
individual i like what she's doing let
her share
as a permanent conservator with the
father on the personal affairs but i
think
everyone is hoping that ultimately the
court is going to say
brittany you've been handling your own
affairs you're doing it well and you can
do it on your own so hopefully that will
ultimately be the decision of the court
hopefully
and jeanette the free britney movement
is kind of fascinating
but her fans say this isn't just about
britney so what is it about
yeah it's pretty interesting when you
actually talk to some of them
a lot of them have done a lot of reading
on the conservatorship
statutes the rules of them the the
issues surrounding them and a lot of
them say they think that the system
needs to be reformed because basically
when people
are under a conservatorship is
incredibly difficult in california to
get out of one
so it's almost like a permanent thing
typically when people are in a
conservatorship it's because
they're really ill and they can't make
decisions for themselves so
a lot of her fans think it's not just
about brittany it's about the
conservatorship
the whole legal issue itself definitely
cases like this draw attention to
large issues in the criminal justice
system or even conservatorships and
maybe this will cause some change in
that structure not just in brittany's
life
coming up on law and crime daily there
are many ways to become a prom queen and
get
great grades but there is one way to do
that
and end up arrested you don't want to
miss this plus
why it's never a good idea to talk back
to a judge the tough work us public
defenders have to do
[Music]
next
[Music]
welcome back march 18 1962
public defenders were created usually we
protect clients from the state
sometimes from themselves as long crime
founder and host of the a
e series court camp tells us one
defendant just didn't know
when enough was enough he's high risk so
i'm gonna raise the bond to five
thousand word bond court in louisville
kentucky
yeah i think a thousand is reasonable
given that these are felony charges
good luck sir judge smith has a full
plate of bond hearings
i actually have a card that i'm trying
to sell on craigslist stop stop talking
i'm gonna give you a public defender
michael ray cases 87 and 88.
next up is michael ray who's facing four
charges
including criminal trespassing and
second-degree assault
a bond or a bail hearing is usually a
quick proceeding
if the defendant is cooperative the
prosecutor suggests a bail amount for
ray
based on the crime in the defendant's
history the county is requesting 25 000
full cash buying all charges you think
that's funny
we weren't done ray might feel 25 000
is too high but sarcasm won't get him a
reduction
and the judge lets him know it all right
so bond is fifty thousand dollars no
bail credit
dangerous community thinks these are
funny charges
i was lucky i didn't hold him in
contempt ray just had his bond doubled
but as he re-enters the hallway he has
something else to say
uh keep bringing him in i'm holding him
in contempt
ray's language isn't the only thing to
upset the judge
according to court officials the
defendant also gave her the middle
finger
[Music]
30 days to serve on contempt for
flipping me off twice judge calls him
back
but it looks like he's gone if we bring
him back in he's just gonna get another
30 days for doing something else
so they move on to the next case case
number 90 scott raymer
when sure enough rey comes back for more
oh here
sir i'm holding you in contempt for what
you did what you're holding me in
and so you're making that works man
all right you can take him back 100 days
to serve 100 days
okay
that's right the judge just gave him a
hundred days in jail
he's done where he could just walk away
without making matters even worse
but he goes a different route
yeah can we bring him back he's got to
be charged
yes what started out as four
serious charges has grown into a grand
total of 10
on the span of approximately three
minutes
no i figure that's just a lesson on what
not to do so you all are good
core cam air is wednesday at 9 00 pm on
the a e networks
when we come back vanessa bryant
publicly names the officers accused of
sharing horrific photos
of a crash that claimed nine lives the
names and the lawsuit
next
welcome back let's check in on some top
legal news
making headlines at the long crime
network
actor johnny depp is accusing his
ex-wife amber heard of lying about
donating her 7 million
divorce settlement to charity depp is
asking a uk court of appeal
for a retrial of his libel claim against
the british tabloid the sun
the sun published a report in april 2019
calling depp
a quote wife beater heard testified
during the libel trial
as a star witness for the sun detailing
several instances
in which she says depp assaulted her
attorneys for depth say the truth of her
claim about donating the money to
charity
would have impacted her credibility as a
witness
a mother and daughter are accused of
rigging the vote to make sure she would
be
homecoming queen the florida department
of law enforcement says an assistant
principal
laura rose carroll gave her 17 year old
daughter access to her school district
account
investigators determined the daughter
then cast more than 117 votes for
herself
in her high school's homecoming court
the fdle also says the daughter used the
account
to look at her classmates grades they
were both arrested and are facing
several criminal charges
more than a year after the death of nba
legend kobe bryant
his widow vanessa is taking to social
media to post the names of the sheriff's
deputies
accused of sharing photos of the
helicopter crash
kobe bryant his daughter gianna and
seven others died last january
after the helicopter they were riding in
and crashed in california
after the crash several los angeles
county sheriff's deputies are accused of
sharing unauthorized and graphic photos
of the deadly scene vanessa bryant is
suing the sheriff's department
seeking damages for negligence and
invasion of privacy
a federal judge rejected the sheriff's
office request to keep the names of the
accused deputies
under seal now vanessa bryan has shared
portions of her lawsuit on instagram
circling the names of the four deputies
the lawsuit accuses deputy joey cruz of
sharing photos of kobe bryant's body
with a bartender
and three others of passing around
gratuitous photos of the dead children
parents and coaches according to the
lawsuit none of the deputies were
directly involved in the crash
nor had a legitimate purpose in sharing
the photos the los angeles county
sheriff says
that someone at the bar overheard the
conversation and reported to law
enforcement
the lawsuit goes on to say that within
48 hours of the crash
at least 10 members of the sheriff's
department obtained photos of the
victim's remains on their personal cell
phones
the sheriff says the photos have since
been deleted the ntsb
concluded last month that decisions made
by the pilot during the flight
led to the helicopter crash he didn't
follow any of
the recommended uh mitigations
for entering uh instrument
meteorological conditions
or to properly once he had entered them
configure the aircraft
by slowing down by starting a climb
by activating the autopilot none of that
happened the sheriff posted on twitter
wednesday night
we will refrain from trying this case in
the media and will wait for the
appropriate venue
our hearts go out to all the families
affected by this tragedy
here with us one last time is suanne
robinson and terry austin
so and it's a little ironic that the
deputies accused of sharing photos
or asking for privacy and not having
their names released but they
decided against that do you agree with
that decision
absolutely this is a hard tragic lesson
and what's good for the goose is good
for the gander
and if they thought it was appropriate
to overstep their professional bounds
and share these photos with people in
the public then they can be the stars
they can get photo credit for doing such
a horrible thing and i'm pretty sure
liability is there especially since they
weren't even involved in the case they
were literally there acting as paparazzi
with badges it's very sad
paparazzi with badge is a great way to
describe it terry you know me i'm
pro-defense i'm always looking for an
argument but is there a defense by the
sheriffs
that i'm missing because it seems like
uh they should probably settle
you know i agree with you and i agree
with suen there is
no question that there is liability here
the own report from the sheriff's office
says that
they failed to even try to track down
copies of the photos
try to sequester the copies of those
photos and so her claim for negligence
and invasion of privacy i think
is a really strong claim and what's you
know good for the goose is good for the
gander
she's named these individuals in her
lawsuit she has every right to do so
the judge previously ruled that she has
every right to do so
so i think the case should you know
proceed forward
or to your point ryan maybe the
sheriff's office and the authorities
should consider
settling because i don't think they have
a valid defense
yeah my thing is not only do i not see
much of a defense but real quick terry
can you imagine a trial in the la region
where kobe bryant is the person who's
dead what juror is going to vote
against that family well that's right
we're in california and we know that
that is a huge
area for a kobe fan so they should
settle yeah
california la america the world all kobe
friends
thank you for joining us ladies and
thank you for joining us here along
crime daily we'll see you next time
as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you